today I'm going to teach you the quads
that belong in the key of C now you
might wonder why the key of C we learnt
the key of G first and C seems like a
bit of a jump when you think about how
far apart they are in terms of notes so
why is C a logical next step so now I'll
give you two reasons number one just
like a lot of music that's written for
the guitar is written in the key of G
because G is easy to play on a guitar a
lot of music room for the piano is
written in the key of C because C is
easy to play on a piano now this is not
a piano but you'll often be playing
along with a piano if you're going to be
in a band of any kind so if music is in
the key of C then you need to know the
key of C as well so that's the first
reason if it's pianos were on there for
you often be playing it the second
reason is once you have a key of G you
almost already know all of the chords in
the key of C there's a lot of chords in
common and it's partly because if you
remember in the key of G the chord C is
the fourth chords the sub-dominant now
because of that relationship I have to
do with the circle of fifths if you want
to go and research that because of that
relationship these two keys are very
very closely connected in fact most of
the chords are the same and I just
quickly run through them before I do
them one by one so you can see how many
are identical so the first chord
obviously is C the second is D minor
the third is a minor
fourth is f the fifth is G and the
relative minor the sixth is the a minor
so you can see out of those six chords
the only new ones are the D minor and
the F you know the rest of them and you
know that that makes it a lot easier to
learn the courts so let's give this a go
let's let's start from the top again the
tonic the first chord is C and again I
play with four fingers I like having
that g base there that's just a personal
preference now the next chord is a D
minor now in the key of D G we learnt
the D major which looks like this
now the D minor only changes a single
note in fact you'll find going from
major to minor you're just changing one
note now instead of playing on zero to
three - you're going to have to move a
finger actually you don't have to move a
few fingers just so you can change a
single string and a single fret instead
you're going to play zero two three one
so you see that that single note makes
the chords sound sad so how do you do it
yeah unfortunately well most people
cannot reach the D minor from the normal
way they play a D so this is the normal
way you play a D and I'm using these one
two three those fingers I'm leaving off
the pinkie now for the D minor I use the
pinkie and I skip my ring finger the
reason why is because when you think out
the distance from fret 1 which my index
finger is holding here on the first
string and fret 3 which my little finger
is holding on the second string it's
quite a distance you could I suppose you
could reach it with your ring finger but
it's a bit of a stretch and you know
your little finger is kind of just there
sitting there you might as well use it
so just again I've got my index finger
on the first fret first string my little
finger on the third fret second string
and my middle finger on the second fret
of the third string and then just like
with the D the regular D you only play
those top four strings
there's Dimona okay now the e-minor
you remember that one from the key of G
so it's what there's a super simple
chord okay but while I'm here I'm going
to teach you another chord along with
this so remember I just said to go from
a D to a D minor we just changed a
single string a single fret right well
to go from an E minor to an E major you
also only have to change a single string
a single fret and I'll show you why I'm
teaching unity major in a second so how
do you play the e major with this some
index finger here you want to hand that
free if you are playing your emailer
with your first two fingers your index
and your middle you want to rotate them
around so you're using your middle
finger and your ring like so then use
your spare index finger and hold down a
third string on the first fret now when
you play that
that sounds a bit happier does it so
that's an E major okay now the reason
why I'm showing you the E major is
because you're going to take this shape
and it's going to form the F major which
is the sub dominant at the fourth chord
in the key of C so again one more time
I'm going to rotate my fingers around so
I'm by rotate by the way I mean instead
of using say fingers one two three I
want to use fingers two three four so
I'm gonna bring my my pinky in here okay
so how am I going to do this I'll have
my middle finger on the first fret of
the third string then I'll use my ring
finger and my little finger to hold down
the second fret on the 4th and 5th
strings so there's my a major now how do
you play an F major well you just take
this shape and you move the whole thing
up
one semitone so one fret so if I move
them is up like so so now instead of
playing 1 2 2 1 2 together
I'm they're gonna be playing 2 3 3
that's gonna form most of the chord but
because I've got um I still have this e
string key and if you remember from the
previous video on the key of G the main
note that you need yet is the bass note
right so I need to change this e into an
F and I also need to change this B and
this e into a C and an F so I need to
hold down all those strings and this is
what we call a barre chord
and that's an F major now bar chords are
really hard to learn I said in a
previous two and then I talked about
this so this is the time because the F
is a really important chord it's a sub
dominant in this key so you're going to
be using it quite a lot so a couple of
things firstly when you're forming the
chord because you've got four fingers to
choose from which one are you going to
place first well you basically want to
form the shape that you're going to bar
which is in this case the ear shape that
I showed you before form there more
first and then form the bar with your
index finger last okay now the reason
why you do that is because if you form
the bar first then all of your strength
is kind of being focused onto your index
finger so then you'll have a lot of
difficulty being agile and quick with
your remaining three fingers it's quite
hard to get them into position versus
doing them first and then barring last
okay secondly how do you get the
strength to form a bar chord because not
only is it harder it just it just hurts
when you when you're playing at the
beginning because you can even you may
even be able to see all of them the
strings are being held down by this one
finger so you've got you know not sit
one mark here but six marks along there
so how do you do that what I advise you
do is um go to a toy store or something
like that and buy a stress ball now I
don't mean one of those like wimpy
stress balls which is like really soft
and it's easy to squash find the the
firmest hardest stress ball you can what
which actually requires a fair bit of
strength to UM to push just funny it
seems like that would make give you more
stress rather than less but anyway find
one of those and then when you've got a
spare moment you watching TV or you're
studying you're doing like a pass paper
or something and you're just riding with
one hand your other hand your fretting
hand is free and what you want to do is
you want to just in probably sort of
thirty to sixty second lot just use your
the stress ball to provide resistance to
press down and clench your fist over and
over again now what will happen is
because that takes a lot of effort your
fingers will gain strength now why would
you do that why not just play the chords
and um develop a strength that way and
the main reason is if you are developing
your strength at the same
as you are learning technique one of
them will probably suffer that doesn't
have to be that way a lot of people
learn chords and this is the only way
they do it but I my experience is if
you're trying to form the chord but the
court is weak right what you'll do is
you'll be tempted to hold it the wrong
way to try and develop more strength and
and thereby compromising your technique
or vice versa
you get your technique right but because
your finger strength is just not there
it won't sound probably because you just
aren't strong enough to hold it in that
position
so I recommend I'm getting a stretch
ball that kind developing that strength
do it in your spare times and all that
kind of thing and then when you come to
play the guitar you'll be like oh my
fingers can do this okay so there's the
F
what's the next chord number five which
is the dominant coin is a G so you guys
know that already while I'm talking
about bar chords though if you remember
what we did to form the S we just took
the e and moved it up one now between an
F and a G there are two semitones or one
tone there's the F then the F sharp then
the G so if you want to and sometimes
there are reasons to do this if you
instead of playing a G like this you may
actually play the G as an F moved up to
or an e moved up three so F F sharp and
he's a G okay and you're like why would
I do that
I hate bar chords I want to avoid them
at all costs that's fair enough and then
the main way you'll play G is like this
but if you pay close attention number
one this G and this G
sounds slightly different there's a
couple of reasons for that which I'll go
into another time so the first thing is
they're actually slightly different
chords and the second thing is when you
are holding down a G with a bar chord
it's much easier to mute the strings to
change the rhythm they like isn't
reading strings a bad thing usually it
is but if you want to sometimes some
songs you'll want to actually stop the
chords playing at certain times so
something like that is much easier to do
when you're actually buying all the
chords rather than if you're not buying
them and you need to mute with this hand
rather than with your Freddie here so
that's how to play the g and then you've
got to finish it off the relative minor
which is the a minor you guys already
know from the key of G and that's it
that's all of the chords in the key of C